Vous faites quoi avec mes bocaux à confiture là ?
Tu fous les jetons là !
On capture des insectes.
Pourquoi vous faites ça ?
Y avait des insectes. Y avait des bocaux. Ça paraît normal non ?
On a vu une bataille de scarabée tout à l’heure.
OK. Je vous emmène en stage avec moi, c’est ça où vous dormez dehors ce soir.
Oui, je l’avoue, je fais partie de ces gens qui peuvent s’extasier devant un bousier au milieu de la forêt.
Mais les détails de leur morphologie et la nuance de leur couleur c’est tellement ouf !
Bon ok, j’vais pas vous parler de ça aujourd’hui, même si franchement vous ratez quelque chose.
Du coup un truc que j’aime bien faire quand j’me balade dans la nature,
c’est de me mettre à la place des espèces que j’croise,
d’imaginer leur vie quotidienne…
Et beh c’est pas toujours jojo !
J’vous plante le décor rapidos et après promis on ira directement sur le terrain
et j’vous parlerai de mon histoire d’amour avec une truite…
Aaah Patrick… Hm pardon…
Vous le savez, nous sommes dans la 6e extinction de masse de la biodiversité.
Entre le changement climatique, la surexploitation des espèces et la destruction des habitats, beh la biodiv elle fait un peu la tronche.
Et la destruction des habitats, c’est quand même une des principales causes de l’appauvrissement de la biodiversité.
Aujourd’hui, un paysage qui n’est pas transformé ou un milieu naturel qui n’est pas morcelé, c’est plutôt rare.
Vous voyez ce que c’est la fragmentation des habitats ?
Si si, vous voyez ce que c’est !
Par exemple, la construction d’une autoroute : fragmentation.
L’intensification de l’agriculture : fragmentation.
Un barrage au milieu d’une rivière ?
Bah fragmentation.
Yes.
Bon évidemment il existe mille et une façon de déglinguer la nature,
et on est plutôt fort pour ça,
mais en gros, la fragmentation, c’est transformer une surface continue d’habitats naturels
en plusieurs fragments plus ou moins nombreux, plus ou moins petits, et plus ou moins isolés les uns des autres.
Vous l’aurez compris, je me place ici uniquement dans un contexte « récent » où la fragmentation et la destruction des habitats est en lien avec les activités humaines.
Les interactions intra et interspécifiques, c'est-à-dire entre individus d’une même espèce et entre espèces différentes,
sont tellement complexes que les conséquences de ce morcellement sur la diversité du vivant
et le fonctionnement des écosystèmes peuvent être catastrophiques.
On va voir ça un peu plus tard avec des exemples concrets.
La fragmentation des habitats c’est donc de la grosso mierda
et ça flingue la continuité écologique.
C’est là où j’voulais en venir, la continuité écologique.
Késsessé ?
Et bien c’est l’ensemble des réservoirs de biodiversité et des corridors écologiques.
Un réservoir de biodiversité c’est un espace où la biodiversité est vraiment riche, un peu comme un hotspot.
Les espèces, faune et flore, peuvent y accomplir leur cycle de vie complet ou en partie, parce qu’elles y trouvent des conditions de vie favorables.
Ces réservoirs vont abriter des populations d’espèces où les individus peuvent se disperser, c'est-à-dire aller conquérir de nouveaux territoires,
et ils ont également une taille suffisamment importante pour accueillir de nouvelles populations d’espèces.
Les corridors écologiques ou biologiques, on peut dire les deux,
quant à eux font le lien entre les réservoirs de biodiversité, ils en assurent les connexions.
Les espèces peuvent s’y déplacer facilement mais également se nourrir, se cacher, dormir : en gros, continuer leur vie.
Dans le cadre d’une continuité écologique où l’humain est présent, on peut identifier trois types de corridors différents.
Les structures linéaires comme les haies ou bords de chemins ; les corridors en « pas japonais », ce sont des îlots-refuges comme des mares ou des bosquets ;
et les corridors de type paysager comme les milieux agricoles, qui sont souvent artificialisés.
La continuité écologique c’est donc tout ça réuni.
Alors évidemment quand tu construis une autoroute en plein milieu d’un réservoir ou d’un corridor,
bah ça va marcher beaucoup moins bien.
Dans ce contexte de fragmentation des habitats, le Ministère de l’écologie a initié en 2007 via le Grenelle de l’environnement,
une politique publique permettant de : casser des culs…
Nan c’est faux…
permettant la mise en place d’un outil de préservation de la biodiversité : la Trame verte et bleue.
Un réseau de continuités écologiques terrestres (la trame verte) et aquatiques (la trame bleue).
L’objectif ? Freiner l’érosion de la biodiversité en préservant et en remettant en bon état les continuités écologiques.
Les populations d’espèces animales et végétales doivent pouvoir se déplacer librement et se nourrir, se reproduire, se cacher, bref faire leur vie trankilou sans obstacles et dans des milieux en bonne santé.
Cette Trame verte et bleue, elle est inscrite dans le code de l’environnement et dans le code de l’urbanisme,
c’est un outil d’aménagement du territoire qui prend en compte la biodiversité et notamment la biodiversité ordinaire. Et ça moi j’aime bien !
J’vous ai parlé de Patrick ? La truite avec qui j’ai vécu euuuh
nan rien, j’peux pas raconter ça ici…
La Trame verte et bleue doit pouvoir s’emboiter sur différentes échelles spatiales, parce que si on s’intéresse aux déplacements de l’ours brun par exemple,
la superficie de son territoire ne sera pas la même que pour le crapaud commun.
La Trame se fait donc à différentes échelles en fonction des espèces étudiées :
continentale, nationale, régionale et même communale.
Bon allez go, il est temps d’aller sur le terrain pour voir concrètement comment des infrastructures de nos vies quotidiennes
peuvent affecter différentes espèces terrestres et aquatiques sans même qu’on s’en rende compte.
Bon, on y va ?
Moi, je suis prête.
On commence avec la Trame verte, et vous allez le voir, la continuité écologique ça paraît simple, mais ce n’est pas si évident que ça.
En 2015, des scientifiques de l’Irstea et notamment Anne Villemey, doctorante à l’époque,
ont étudié l’influence de l’organisation des paysages agricoles sur la distribution des papillons de jour.
Ce sont de bons indicateurs de la qualité de l’environnement parce qu’ils réagissent rapidement aux modifications de leurs milieux, entre autres.
Dans les milieux agricoles, les éléments herbacés sont souvent morcelés et de forme linéaire.
Alors est ce que connecter les prairies, lieux de nourrissages et de reproductions pour les papillons,
et les linéaires enherbés comme les chemins agricoles ou les bords de routes,
est-ce que ça c’est utile et efficace pour les papillons ?
Est-ce que la connectivité de ces milieux est importante finalement ?
Pour ça, les chercheurs ont utilisé deux approches : l’écologie des communautés et l’écologie du paysage.
Ils ont échantillonné les communautés de papillons sur des transects, c'est-à-dire sur des lignes virtuelles ou matérialisées sur le terrain,
dans différents paysages d’études.
Puis ils ont analysé la réponse des communautés aux caractéristiques de l’habitat et du paysage :
type de végétation, intensité de gestion, connectivité des bois et des prairies etc.
Je vous mets le lien de l’étude sous la vidéo parce que là je condense beaucoup.
Les résultats ont montré que la diversité des papillons est d’abord influencée par la qualité de l’habitat et le paysage environnant.
Les prairies hébergent des communautés diversifiées tandis que les linéaires enherbés abritent des communautés appauvries
mais favorisent la dispersion et la diversité génétique de certaines espèces.
Et même s’ils peuvent favoriser la dispersion des papillons, ils ne sont pas suffisants pour préserver les espèces sédentaires et spécialistes.
En tout cas, pour les espèces identifiées dans cette étude.
La dispersion des espèces est un processus important pour la biodiversité, mais ce n’est pas le seul.
Connecter les paysages ok, mais il ne faut pas sous-estimer l’importance de la qualité des milieux.
Dans certains cas, préserver des milieux en bonne santé ou restaurer des habitats dégradés auront plus d’impact que d’augmenter leur connexion.
La stratégie à adopter (connecter ou restaurer) dépendra du paysage, des espèces ciblées, de plein de facteurs différents.
Il faut faire du cas par cas à chaque fois.
Mais d’une manière générale, l’un ne va pas sans l’autre.
Surtout qu’en France, les espaces agricoles couvrent plus de la moitié du territoire.
Se tourner vers une agriculture durable qui prend en compte la préservation de la biodiversité,
ça existe, et certains appellent ça l’agro-écologie.
Bon et en ville alors, comment ça se passe niveau biodiversité et continuité écologique ?
Et du coup, en ville, la biodiversité, ça se passe comment ?
Alors en ville, on a fait des efforts.
Surtout depuis qu’on a mis la trame verte et bleue dans les plans d’urbanisation.
Ça s’améliore, mais y a quand même des petits points, des petits réservoirs de biodiversité
qui existent depuis très longtemps.
Les cimetières par exemple. On y pense pas souvent, mais c’est un des endroits où on a encore des arbres, des herbes folles, etc.
Après il y a les parcs, puis il y a aussi des jardins collectifs par exemple.
Ouais, mais des jardins collectifs, y en a pas énormément, y en a pas partout non plus.
Y en a pas trop trop, mais ça n’a pas toujours été le cas, parce qu’en fait, les jardins collectifs,
les jardins ouvriers, ça a été inventé, comme beaucoup de choses, au XIXe siècle.
Mais ça a connu un essor pendant l’occupation.
Parce que sous l’occupation, on avait besoin de manger.
Pour pallier la pénurie, on encourageait les gens à avoir un potager.
Mais en plus de ça, y avait tout un esprit de retour à la terre, la mère patrie, la famille.
Et donc, on passe de jardins ouvriers à jardins familiaux.
Aujourd’hui, on essaie de remettre un équilibre.
On essaie de préserver les friches.
Notamment les friches industrielles et les friches ferroviaires. Par exemple, la petite ceinture à Paris.
Pareil pour les bords des canaux ou des fleuves,
qui traversent les villes, on va les reverdir, et hop,
ça te refait des couloirs où tu peux avoir une circulation.
Et puis, ce qui est intéressant aussi, c’est que ça se voit sur les plans
et du coup, tu as les chercheurs qui y voient aussi un aspect plus sociologique
et ils s’aperçoivent que ça contribue à ce qu’ils appellent l’esthétique environnementale.
C’est-à-dire que cette trame verte et bleue, ces espaces verts,
notamment que tu vois sur les plans,
ça va aider le citadin, qui est un peu en mal de retour à la nature,
à se figurer la qualité de vie qu’il va pouvoir avoir.
Comme ça, ça contribue à un imaginaire finalement.
Il y a également des espèces concernées par la Trame verte ET bleue.
C’est le cas par exemple des amphibiens : grenouilles, crapauds, salamandres et autres tritons.
Ils font partie des vertébrés terrestres les plus menacés.
Partout dans le monde, c’est l’extinction de leurs populations.
Et devinez quelles sont les causes principales ?
Ouais ! La destruction et la fragmentation de leurs habitats.
La plupart des amphibiens ont un cycle de vie complexe et alternent entre milieux aquatiques pour la reproduction, la ponte et le développement des larves
et les milieux terrestres pour les juvéniles et les adultes où ils vont se nourrir et s’y réfugier.
Ils vont donc utiliser plusieurs types d’habitats au cours de leur vie :
des habitats de reproduction, de chasse, un site d’estivation et un autre d’hivernage.
Ce sont des animaux qui bougent, migrent et se dispersent pour conquérir de nouveaux territoires.
Entre les différents types d’habitats et selon les espèces, les distances peuvent aller de plusieurs centaines de mètres à plusieurs kilomètres.
Et pour éviter de se faire boulotter sur le chemin, de se dessécher, et pour minimiser l’énergie dépensée à se déplacer, les amphibiens, ils font du tout droit.
Ils prennent la distance la plus courte et go, ligne droite,
ils contournent pas, ils ont pas l’time.
Et quand ils rencontrent une route… bah ils traversent…
Je ne vous fais pas un dessin, c’est souvent un carnage.
Y’a des effets directs et indirects du réseau routier sur les amphibiens.
Bon bah la perte et la fragmentation des habitats oui, les collisions mortelles, ok,
mais aussi les pollutions chimiques avec les hydrocarbures ou le salage des routes,
les pollutions sonores et lumineuses, etc.
On n’y pense pas forcément hein à tous ces impacts ?
Conséquences ? Augmentation des distances entre les différents habitats, isolements des populations,
extinction à certains endroits, et j’en passe…
Grosse ambiance ! Quand la continuité écologique est brisée, coloniser de nouveaux territoires ou migrer pour se reproduire ou s’alimenter
c’est compliqué, voire impossible parfois.
D’après une estimation, parce que ce n’est pas évident de savoir précisément, ce serait entre 25 et 50 millions d’amphibiens adultes
qui se feraient écraser en France, tous les ans.
Entre 25 et 50 millions, je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez compte, c’est énorme !
Heureusement il existe des solutions, qui fonctionnent plus ou moins, mais elles ont le mérite d’exister.
Quand cela est possible, des routes peuvent être fermées pendant quelques semaines en période de migration.
On peut également installer des dispositifs temporaires le long des routes comme des barrières provisoires pour empêcher les amphibiens de traverser.
Ces barrières sont souvent accompagnées de seaux placés à des endroits stratégiques pour que les amphibiens tombent dedans.
Les animaux piégés sont récupérés quotidiennement, voire plusieurs fois par nuit en cas de pic,
le plus souvent par des bénévoles qui les aident à traverser les obstacles en tout sécurité.
Quand des points chauds d’écrasements sont identifiés, il est possible de mettre en place des dispositifs permanents.
C’est le cas par exemple des célèbres crapauducs.
Un système qui permet aux amphibiens de traverser les routes en passant sous la chaussée.
Alors les autres  espèces peuvent aussi  emprunter ces canalisations mais elles  sont spécialement conçus pour les amphibiens.
Pour les autres espèces vous avez peut-être déjà croisés ce qu’on appelle les passages à faune ou écoduc.
Des passerelles végétalisées, le plus souvent au-dessus des routes, qui facilitent les déplacements de la faune et de la flore.
Ouais, la flore aussi se déplace. Je s’appelle Groot.
On a donc des espèces terrestres qui sont concernés que par la Trame verte,
d’autres amphibies qui utilisent les Trames vertes et bleues,
et pour les espèces uniquement aquatiques du coup ? Genre les poissons ?
Genre Patrick ? Ah oui nan c’est vrai, j’ai pas l’droit d’en parler…
Ah, bah on va pouvoir utiliser Mam’Route…
C’est quoi ça ?
C’est une appli où dès que tu vois un mammifère mort sur la route,
tu l’enregistres et ça te permet d’identifier des points noirs,
des lieux hyper fréquentés par la faune et après proposer des aménagements pour les aider à traverser en toute sécurité.
Mais c’est trop bien ! C’est mieux que Pokémon Go ça.
- Mais c’est quoi ce truc là ?
- Ah ça !
Bah là je dirais un chevreuil…
ou peut-être un hérisson ?
On peut le ramener ?
Pour quoi faire?
Bah du gras de porc, des chutes de lapin, 180° au bain-marie, 3h au four, et on a une terrine.
- J’ai de la place dans mon tote bag si vous voulez.
- Non mais vous êtes possédés, on ne va pas manger ça.
Ça va, tu mangeras des carottes râpées.
Gngngn, tu mangeras des carottes râpées.
La continuité écologique des cours d’eau, comment ça fonctionne ?
Et bien comme la continuité écologique terrestre.
C’est la libre circulation des organismes vivants, l’accès aux zones vitales pour accomplir leur cycle de vie,
le bon état des réservoirs biologiques, mais s’ajoute à ça la libre circulation des sédiments.
Et pourquoi donc ?
Ah bah c’est bien que tu en parles, parce que, les bestioles, ça va deux minutes, mais qui parle des sédiments après, qui parle des cailloux ?
Oui parce que les barrages et les digues et tous ces trucs-là, ça va affecter la circulation des sédiments, ce qu’on appelle le transit sédimentaire,
si tu fais un barrage, ça va sédimenter en amont,
et en aval, il y aura de l’érosion contraire, parce que le budget sédimentaire est négatif, il n’y a plus assez de caillasse.
Et du coup, ça, ça va affecter les bestioles qui y vivent et tout.
Et y a un autre truc qui est important, c’est le fonctionnement même du barrage qui est d’ouvrir plus ou moins les vannes,
et du coup, tu as des bestioles qui se prennent des baffes d’eau comme ça, et ça fait pas forcément du bien quoi.
Ouais, c’est pas génial.
Il y a une zone particulièrement stratégique, c’est l’interface entre l’eau et le substrat, le sol,
parce qu’il y a des tonnes de bestioles qui vivent dedans, notamment des invertébrés qu’on appelle les benthiques.
C’est ceux qui vivent dans le sol, et en fait, les sédiments, c’est leur maison.
Genre, les insectes qui s’appellent les tricoptères, je trouve ça génial,
n fait ils se fabriquent un cornet, qui s’appelle un fourreau avec tout ce qu’ils trouvent.
Ça peut être des grains de sable, ça peut être des vieilles branches, des bouts de feuille, des trucs comme ça.
Et ils vivent littéralement dans une maison qu’ils se fabriquent eux-mêmes en sédiment.
Et à côté des barrages, il y a tout ce qui est lié, ce que tu mets sur les berges, par exemple, les embranchements ou quand tu bétonnes le bord des cours d’eau pour empêcher que ça érode,
ça empêche la rivière de suivre son cours normal parce qu’une rivière normalement ça divague.
Vague.
Exactement. Parce qu’un cours d’eau, c’est jamais fixe. Ça passe par un méandre, tout ça,
et ça condamne tout ce qui est accès à des zones annexes, ça peut être des bras morts, ça peut être des mares, ça peut être des zones humides.
Plein de trucs qui servent énormément aux bestioles qui vivent dans les rivières.
Notamment pour tout ce qui est frayères, ce sont les zones de reproduction des poissons.
Si tu prends les brochets par exemple, eux, ils vont frayer sur le bord des rivières quand tu as une crue.
Ils vont sur ce qu’on appelle la plaine alluviale de chaque côté là.
Ils vont dans les herbes et c’est là où ils pondent les œufs.
Après, ils retournent dans l’eau, et les œufs éclosent et après les alevins vivent leur vie.
Regarde, il y a plein de petits poissons qui utilisent justement les sédiments.
Ça se mange en friture ça ?
Alors non.
T’es sûre ?
Oui.
Les rivières sont donc...
Si tu nous cherches, on est là-bas.
Vous allez faire quoi ?
Un barrage.
- Pour quoi faire ?
- Bah pour le casser, c’est marrant.
Mais c'est pas possible en fait !
Les cours d’eau sont donc à la fois des réservoirs de biodiversité et des corridors écologiques.
On a vu ce qu’il se passait pour les sédiments mais pour les poissons comment ça se passe niveau obstacle ? Bah ça passe pas.
Certaines espèces de poissons se déplacent dans le même type de milieu pour accomplir leur cycle de vie.
D’ailleurs c’est comme ça que j’ai rencontré Patrick. Patrick la truite. Chuuut.
Elles effectuent ce qu’on appelle des migrations holobiotiques.
Et ça marche autant pour le brochet qui reste en rivière, que la morue qui elle reste en mer.
D’autres espèces effectuent quant à elles des migrations amphibiotiques. Et les amphibiotiques, c’est pas automatique…
Ces espèces passent une partie de leur cycle de vie en mer et l’autre en rivière.
Elles sont thalassotoques quand elle se reproduisent en mer et grandissent en rivière, comme l’anguille européenne ou le mulet porc,
et potamotoques quand c’est l’inverse : repro en rivière et croissance en mer, comme le saumon atlantique, les aloses, ou les lamproies.
Ces poissons migrateurs sont donc susceptibles de rencontrer pas mal d’obstacles au cours de leurs déplacements.
Si j’me mets à la place d’une anguille européenne, et non, je n’prends pas du tout cet exemple parce que c’est mon poisson préf,
qu’il a un cycle de vie incroyable et que j’ai envie que vous l’aimiez aussi, pas du tout…
Pardon Patrick…
Déjà, je vois le jour dans la mer des Sargasses, au large de la Floride.
Enfin, plus ou moins par là, parce que la repro de mon espèce, c’est un grand mystère. J’suis mystérieuse ouai j’sais.
Je dois traverser tout l’atlantique sous forme de larve en me laissant porter par les courants, ça prend entre 7 et 9 mois. Mystérieuse et  badass tavu.
J’arrive sur les côtes européennes où je me suis métamorphosée en civelle, un bébé anguille transparent. En plus d’être badass, j’deviens mignonne.
Disons que j’ai de la chance et que j’échappe aux pêcheurs. Ouai parce que j’suis en danger critique d’extinction mais on continue d’me pêcher.
J’aimerais bien rejoindre la rivière mais aïe, premier obstacle, je suis devant ce qu’on appelle un ouvrage soumis à marée.
Ça peut-être : des portes battantes, des buses, des clapets, des vannes etc.
On va dire que là aussi j’ai un peu de chance et que j’arrive à passer parce que l’ouvrage me le permet plus ou moins.
Ok, j’arrive en eau douce, je commence à me pigmenter, je grandis un peu et j’deviens une anguillette.
Je nage je nage je nage, mon objectif est d’aller le plus loin possible.
Et là bim, barrage hydroélectrique dans ma tronche.
Bon, ça commence à faire beaucoup, mais ok,
là aussi j’ai de la chance, j’arrive à traverser parce que le barrage est muni d’une passe à poissons
et encore mieux d’un dispositif spécifique pour les anguilles. Merci les gars, et les filles !
Je reprends mes forces et je colonise le bassin versant tout en devenant une belle anguille jaune. Oui j’ai dit belle oui.
Évidemment en rivière je vais encore tomber sur plein d’obstacles qui vont m’empêcher de coloniser l’amont des cours d’eau :
des seuils, des barrages, des digues… des points complètement bloquants qui vont me stopper.
Je vais quand même rester 3 à 18 ans en rivière pour grandir, grossir, toussa toussa.
Comme j’suis une anguille hyper chanceuse (en plus d’être mystérieuse, badass et canon... ouais ça fait beaucoup pour une seule personne je sais)
j’ai vécu dans un endroit en bonne santé, j’ai évité les pêcheurs, il est temps de me métamorphoser une nouvelle fois pour devenir une anguille argentée et commencer ma dévalaison,
c’est à dire descendre le cours d’eau.
Ah bah ouai, parce que du coup je dois faire tout le chemin inverse,
éviter de me faire décapiter dans les turbines du barrage, repasser par l’ouvrage soumis à marée,
traverser l’atlantique une 2e fois pour aller me reproduire vers la mer des Sargasses où j’vais mourir par la suite.
Ouais tout ça pour ken…
Piouf, et bah c’était pas de la tarte !
Les anguilles européennes sont des méga warriors
et j’vous parle pas de toutes les autres espèces qui dans l’ombre qui accomplissent des trucs vraiment ouf pour survivre. Je les adore !
Bon et puis la diversité des dispositifs de franchissements d’ouvrages qui aident les poissons à monter ou descendre les cours d’eau, c’est assez ouf aussi !
Genre des ascenseurs, pour les poissons ouai ! Et le canon à saumons, vous en avez entendu parlé ou pas ? Ouai euh là pauvres bêtes quand même…
Enfin bref, la continuité écologique des cours d’eau et des milieux aquatiques ce n’est pas évident non plus.
Heureusement les acteurs de la préservation de l’environnement travaillent d’arrache-pied avec les propriétaires d’ouvrages et les riverains pour la restaurer.
Sensibiliser le grand public aux enjeux de cette restauration est hyper importante
parce qu’il y a pas mal d’idées reçues sur la destruction des ouvrages et parfois (souvent même) les points bloquants, ce sont les humains.
Ok donc la Trame verte et bleue vise à préserver et à restaurer les continuités écologiques terrestres et aquatiques.
Mais depuis quelques années on entend aussi parler de la Trame noire.
Késsessé qu’ce truc ?
L’humain est un animal diurne.
Pour prolonger son activité de jour en période de nuit, il a produit de la lumière artificielle.
Mais cette lumière, quand elle est excessive, entraîne une pollution lumineuse.
Cette pollution touche toute la planète et la surface des zones artificiellement illuminées augmente d’environ 2% tous les ans.
Elle est donc massive et en croissance.
En plus d’avoir un impact sur la santé humaine, la biodiversité est également touchée.
Faut savoir que la majorité des animaux sont nocturnes : environ 30% des vertébrés et plus de 60% des invertébrés vivent la nuit.
Romain Sordello, ingénieur expert en biodiversité et notamment sur la pollution lumineuse et les continuités écologiques, a bien étudié le sujet.
Dans ses publications, il nous explique notamment le mécanisme de phototactisme.
C’est le fait que certaines espèces soient spontanément attirées ou au contraire repoussées par la lumière.
Les espèces nocturnes peuvent être classées dans ces deux types de comportements. On parle alors de phototactisme positif ou négatif.
Parmi les espèces naturellement attirées par la lumière, on retrouve beaucoup d’insectes.
Vous avez tous déjà observé un lampadaire de nuit et vu des dizaines d’insectes voler autour.
C’est parce qu’ils s’orientent la nuit grâce aux étoiles et à la lune.
Quand ils voient une lumière artificielle, ils reproduisent ce comportement et se dirigent donc vers elle,
restent bloqués près des lampadaires et finissent par mourir d’épuisement ou de collisions.
Cette concentration d’insectes autour des lumières artificielles constitue également une source de nourriture facile pour les prédateurs.
On observe alors un déséquilibre dans l’écosystème car la relation proie-prédateur est perturbée.
Et puis, sur d’autres espèces, on observe le phénomène inverse.
La lumière les repousse. C’est le cas notamment chez certaines espèces de chauves-souris.
Probablement pour éviter la prédation, minimiser les risques de se faire voir.
Si ces espèces évitent les zones éclairées, elles ont donc moins d’espaces dans l’obscurité pour accomplir leur cycle de vie.
Dans ses publications, Romain Sordello parle de fragmentation à l’échelle du paysage.
Et bah oui, parce que les lampadaires s’additionnent et au final forment une barrière lumineuse qui fragmente l’obscurité.
Une route éclairée va empêcher certaines espèces de la traverser alors que d’autres vont se retrouver keblo dessus.
C’est ce qu’on appelle la fragmentation par répulsion ou par absorption.
L’éclairage nocturne constitue un mur totalement infranchissable pour certaines espèces et ça, c’est une connaissance plutôt récente.
Grâce aux études scientifiques et aux travaux naturalistes, les gens ont pris conscience de l’importance d’agir sur cette pollution lumineuse.
Et c’est là qu’intervient la Trame noire, déclinaison de la Trame verte et bleue.
Elle a pour objectif de créer un réseau écologique favorable à la biodiversité nocturne.
Étant donné que la pollution lumineuse augmente tous les ans, l’objectif premier est de préserver des zones sombres déjà existantes
pour qu’elles ne soient pas dégradées dans les années à venir.
Autre objectif : restaurer une obscurité suffisante au sein des continuités écologiques.
Pour ça, une gestion raisonnée de la lumière artificielle est primordiale.
Cette dynamique est nouvelle en France mais dans pas mal de communes l’idée a fait son chemin, c’est une pratique qui devient courante.
Mais est-ce si simple de diminuer cette pollution lumineuse ?
J’ai loupé !
Après c’est sûr qu’au niveau économique, cette question de la pollution lumineuse, elle est vraiment intéressante,
parce que quand on regarde la Terre de nuit et de loin, on se rend compte qu’il y a des coins qui sont vraiment plus lumineux que d’autres,
et généralement ces coins-là, c’est aussi les coins les plus riches.
Et c’est tellement le cas qu’il y a même des économistes qui ont commencé à essayer de calculer la croissance économique de différents coins en partant de cette pollution lumineuse.
Donc ils se disent, ah bah tiens, il y a de nouvelles villes, des nouvelles routes qui se créent, avec ça, il y a de plus en plus de lumière,
et du coup, on va pouvoir en déduire le niveau de vie, la croissance économique de ces régions-là.
Parce qu’au final, le truc c’est qu’il y a de plus en plus de villes et de routes qui sont éclairées,
et jusqu’à maintenant, comme ce que tu disais, on ne se posait pas vraiment la question.
Que ce soit pour des questions de sécurité routière ou autre chose, on mettait de l’éclairage.
Alors maintenant, peut-être que ça va changer, comme tu disais avec le travail des chercheurs, on commence à se poser des questions.
Et peut-être même que dans quelques temps, on ne pourra plus calculer la croissance économique à partir de la pollution lumineuse.
Mais bon, j’imagine que ça, c’est un peut-être.
Ouais, en fait, tout ça, c’est vraiment nouveau, il y a déjà des chercheurs qui travaillaient là-dessus. Il y a des techniques pour baisser cette pollution lumineuse,
comme jouer sur les caractéristiques de l’éclairage. Des lumières plutôt bleues ou orangées,
ou travailler sur la durée ou sur l’espace, ne pas s’éclairer entre 2h et 6h du matin par exemple.
Des choses comme ça.Je pense qu’à l’avenir, j’espère en tout cas,
il y aura de nouvelles techniques et de nouveaux moyens de gérer au mieux cette pollution lumineuse et ces lumières artificielles.
Et on pourrait même commencer par celle-là.
Ah au fait, j’vous ai pas parlé de la trame bleue marine ?
Nan parce que les mers, elles prennent chères aussi !
Bon ok je m’arrête ici.
Vous en savez désormais un peu plus sur la continuité écologique terrestre et aquatique, de jour comme de nuit.
Les enjeux de sa préservation et de sa restauration sont de plus en plus pris en compte
et bien que des outils existent tels que la Trame verte et bleue,
sensibiliser le grand public reste, à mon avis, tout aussi important.
Car on ne peut pas s’émouvoir de la disparition de certaines espèces si on ne sait même pas qu’elles existent et si on ne connaît pas les menaces qui pèsent sur elles.
Plus on connaît, plus on agit, et mieux on protège.
Et promis un jour, j’vous parlerai de mon histoire d’amour avec une truite…
Et comme cette vidéo est mieux que celle de Manon, vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne du Vortex, mettre un petit commentaire,
la liker et nous, on se retrouve sur le Discord du Vortex.
Parce qu’il pleut. Et je vais rentrer.
Elle est où Marie-là ?
Je sais pas, il commence à faire un peu froid là ? Faudrait peut-être qu’on rentre à un moment.
Sinon on se barre sans elle.
Tu connais le chemin toi ?
Non, ce qui veut dire qu’on va devoir l’attendre, on va devoir faire le chemin avec elle, elle est relou en plus et tout...
Voilà, t’as vu ce que tu racontes. Qu’est-ce que t’as dit encore !
Non mais, tais-toi, viens, hop. MARIE !
C’était pour rire.
MARIIIIIIIIIIIE !
MaaaAAaaaArrRRRrrrriiiIIIIIiiiieeeEEEEeee !